good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight about 20 minutes into
the 2016 presidential campaign it was
pretty clear the american media were
horribly addicted to donald trump they
hated trump obviously but they also
needed trump in order to live and that's
the face of addiction if you ever seen a
person grimace while gulping warm vodka
before breakfast with shaky hands you
know what it looks like
so there was really never any question
about what was gonna happen for sure
when news organizations were finally cut
off from their vital daily supply of
donald trump
they were going to collapse in a pile
and that's exactly what they've done
they've collapsed
on tuesday for example not a single show
on cnn wants the most important cable
news channel in the world this is cnn
not a single show on the whole channel
approached even 800 000 viewers that's
really low
chris como would be better off doing
free concerts in the park which in fact
he may soon be doing
so with trump gone the old formula no
longer works
that's easy to understand what's more
confusing harder to understand is how
they've responded to this fact
so let's say you've made billions of
dollars over the years selling rice
krispie treats to a hungry public
dentist may have complained about what
you were doing but for you it was always
a great business and you assumed it
would go on forever because we always
think everything good will go on forever
but it doesn't
over time consumers start to figure out
that a marshmallow coated with breakfast
cereal not a very healthy food option it
tastes great at first eat enough and it
starts to make you feel sick
so they began to buy less of what you
were selling
following this
how would you react to that
well if you were smart you'd probably
just rebrand you'd change the color
you'd throw in some vitamin additives
you'd rename the product you might call
it crunchy kale treats or healthy life
nutrition bars
you'd have figured out that people don't
want sugary garbage they want something
that's good for them so you would sell
it to them
that seems like a pretty rational choice
what you probably wouldn't do if you
were selling rice krispie treats to a
rapidly shrinking market is convince
yourself that you were not in the snack
food business but instead on some kind
of mission from god
you would not claim that eating
marshmallows is a vital moral imperative
you would not attack your own consumers
for preferring something else
you would not denounce them as morons or
racists for eating less sugar you
wouldn't try and ban the atkins diet
make keto illegal
that would be insane you'd go bankrupt
if you did that
and yet that's exactly what the legacy
media have decided to do as they face
extinction
they've amped up the moral outrage
they've turned the self-righteousness
all the way up to eleven
and above all they pretended that
nothing has changed and that donald j
trump still strides the horizon as a
great orange colossus who threatens the
very existence of this fragile nation
we're not overstating it here's a recent
sample of cable news coverage in this
country and keep in mind as you watch
every one of these clips was recorded
this week
election officials are growing more
fearful for their lives as donald trump
continues his big lie president trump
continues to push lies about the
election about election results across
the country where would where would we
be today if the trump white house simply
listened to the science trump wants to
overturn the next election he wants to
overturn the last one he wants to just
he wants to limit voting and overturn
elections at the state level mitch
mcconnell and kevin mccarthy denounced
the insurrection denounced donald trump
as president trump has found a
surprising new platform to spread the
big lie i mean the thing with trump is
trump is always bad for democracy it has
metastasized much far beyond president
trump right from multiple sources i hear
you there however the original cancer
was president trump
what a freak show no wonder nobody
watches who would watch that but listen
to what they're saying trump wants to
overturn the next election screams the
pudgy [ __ ] they all do
okay got it but the fact is that donald
trump is no longer the president of the
united states he's golfing right now in
florida good for him
how about covering what's happening in
america right now ton of change
maybe you could explain it to us or even
tell us about it nope
they refuse
and they refuse because they are caught
in an earlier age they can't adjust to a
new reality it's depressing when you
think about it that's going to be all of
us someday it's certainly very sad for
them just a few years ago hosting a
sunday show on television was considered
a very big deal especially in washington
now nobody cares it's irrelevant
imagine if you're the host of one of
those shows choctaw doesn't need to
imagine he is the host of one of those
shows he spent his entire life trying to
get this gig only to discover once he
got it that it's not worth having
no wonder he seems so bitter and fragile
here he is earlier this year
this was started when the mainstream
media
stop drop any pretense of being unbiased
and actually chose sides during this
election this fire was started when you
completely ignored for example our
investigation hunter biden you know no
no evidence wrong doing there and now we
find out after the election no there is
a fair amount of evidence to the point
that we have a real fbi investigation
all right
it's the it's no listen i've had enough
of this too
where republicans and conservatives do
not trust the mainstream media and that
is what's recruiting that is what has
destroyed the credibility of the media
and our institutions and right really
you know the destruction confidence in
the intellectual
result so i can start this
senator i've had enough chuck todd
literally can't even bear to listen to
someone criticize the american news
media
oh but he has to now settle down chuck
no one is interested in what you think
anymore your moral authority is long
gone along with your relevance you're
shouting into the void they all are
deep down chuck todd knows that they all
know that but rather than accept the
truth about themselves and their careers
rather than change their behavior or
acquire brand new skills that would be
nice or gracefully retire to cabo again
this is coming for all of us they won't
they have one final hope for keeping
their scam alive and it's censorship
so the dying media companies have
convinced themselves that somehow they
can get the government and their friends
the tech monopolies to shut down their
competitors maybe they can keep it going
maybe they'll be important and lucrative
businesses again maybe we can return to
2003 a time when people delayed their
golf games to watch meet the press
wouldn't that be great
that's their goal
diluted as it is and it explains why all
of a sudden journalists
of all people
are leading the charge against the first
amendment that you thought made their
jobs possible this tells you exactly why
they hate fox news so obsessively and
sub stack too
this is the key to their campaign
against what they call misinformation
now if you're a literal minded person
and we certainly are you laugh every
time you hear them say that
misinformation aren't these the exact
same people who told us that putin got
trump elected the ones who swore that
some high school kid from kentucky was
in the clan
yeah same people
so of course they're not against
misinformation obviously the point is
they want to restore their monopoly on
it
and that's what they're trying to do
so we want to bring you an update right
at the top of the show tonight to the
virginia governor's race that race took
a bizarre and deeply revealing turn
today
so several people carrying torches
neo-nazis showed up in front of a
campaign bus for glenn younkin he's the
republican candidate in that race they
chanted we're all in for glenn
so the entire internet exploded of
course every left-wing influencer on
twitter was telling you see glenn
younkin's a nazi
but it turns out these weren't actually
glenn younkin's supporters it's an
amazing story really hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else